wer spielt wir kommen zu einem neuen bio
heute liebe leute muss ich sagen habe
ich noch nicht ganz erholt von diesem
ganzen brief kramer das lassen wir immer
noch ein bisschen an ich fühle mich
immer noch so ein bisschen mitgenommen
mein kopf ist nicht auf der höhe was
natürlich nicht die mit über das sie
gestern feiern war aber ja nach diesen
ganzen streitereien muss man erst mal
wieder so bisschen reinkommt tägliche
upload deswegen dachte ich mir machen
wir heute zur überbrückung bis ich mich
selbst wiedergefunden habe meine innere
mitte einfach eine versuche nicht
wegzuschauen challenge und würde sagen
will aber nicht weiter und legen los
eine sache leute muss ich noch arbeiten
wer jetzt sagt seite seid dann vergisst
dass wir nicht an einem echten kräftige
sachen drin und ich möchte nicht dass
leute in meinen videos was sehen was sie
eigentlich nicht sehen wollen also
gerade wenn ihr jüngers und zeigt bis
ein empfindlicher sei kein problem ist
dann steckt nur das nächste video an und
mich das war wie gesagt ich möchte nicht
dass die leute irgendwas geben was
technisch sehen sollten schon bereit es
gibt in die mittlerweile regalmeter sfr
nicht gesichert es gibt so dumme
menschen will sie dieses gebäude wie
dumm kann man sein kombi schreckte faust
erkältet die wissen nicht gesichert
manche menschen einfach auf ihr leben ok
dass wir gerade eben habe ich aber nicht
so gekettet wege habe ich jetzt ungefähr
eine halbe stunde lang weitere videos
gesucht und gefunden
[Musik]
leute ich habe jetzt mal ich hab bei
solchen verbrechens immer schiss dass
sie eigentlich mehr langweilig sind und
das ist ein nicht wirklich etwas hier
probleme zu tun muss aber war das mein
gott ich weiß gar nicht ob das so hoch
werden kann sich mal vor man ohne
witzige richtig gänsehaut gerade
[Musik]
glücklich schwärmt ich glaube hier den
ton für euch raus genommen oder
irgendwas sei das areal topleute okay
diese ganzen compilation trainerteam
natur rf feierte was auch immer leute
normalerweise sind diese arbeit das ist
echt das ist echt
ja ich würde dann legen ihr geld unter
[Musik]
ein teil nicht schau dich rein
beide male leute diese autounfällen ich
eigentlich gar nicht so sehr weil was
ich eigentlich mache so fingers tag lang
nicht studieren youtube videos machen
und nicht wie sie entscheiden sondern
ich schaue mir den ganzen tag lang
autobahnen crash compilations an
es ist raus deswegen stark auf diese
autos nicht mehr so weit im aus gesehen
hab aber diese clips oder etwas brechen
jedes online online online online online
online google wenn wir schon so ab
sofort bei caseking aber distanziert bis
jetzt die bestandsaufnahme das einzige
was wirklich reinhardt und gegenstände
ist die kamera zu fliegen und gebrochene
sachen rony barrak lehmann sieht das
video man weiß genau irgendwann richtig
etwas leute schreibt meine kommentare
wie ihr das video fallen weil ich mir
das video echt kraft und ich find das
haut deutlich mehr rein dass man das
eigentlich erwarten würde und main kanal
wird auf jeden fall cool stecken was
gilt wie immer der klassiker es gibt
soweit account diese dinge hofladen kein
problem irgendwo andere youtuber macht
das hier drauf das ist konnte die wir
hier bekommen wollen
von mehr wirklich viel besprechen sein
man kann da aber irgendwie nicht anders
drauf reagieren leute bei diesem video
muss ich einfach wirklich wegschauen
genug für heute ich will nicht wissen
was komisches in kraft
er macht einfach leute das heute kurz
und knackig überbrückungs video bis und
wieder von dem ganzen stadt gerne meine
kommentare wie oft ihr weg geschaut
hatten sagt ehrlich weil ich weiss das
video war bestimmt auch wenn viele von
euch ordentlich last zwei lecks da und
natürlich zeit und bist du nicht mal
leute